hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to giraffe attack now the
absurdity of this game is what drew me
to it it's made by one of my favorite
developers JMT bo2 he's made tons of
games and I'm actually get probably
gonna play today because they're awesome
but this game is just entirely
ridiculous and you'll see why the first
Queen should ever be launched into space
is an ode never mind draft chosen is
first to go for space launch which you
know seems probably normal to any mere
mortal but not to the Russians like the
Russians must take this very very
seriously as the hill the hoods the who
loves mr. half in space and by it
Hey and then his leg oh man I actually
didn't see that I skipped through that
before I slowed it up a game I was
playing this and I thought it was
ridiculous because for one well here
okay for two they're bombing this
giraffe for some reason because the
other countries don't want the USSR to
be first to launch their trip into space
but I thought it was absurd because it
looks like the neck was just stretching
infinitely I didn't realize that was
actually what was happening there I'm
sorry I need to keep my composure this
is serious business and now we have
lasers and this is as far as I played
before because it got a little too
hectic for me and I wanted to save the
rest of it for me actually recording it
but I mean insist it was too silly like
to even think
okay hang on I'm getting a little too
emotional like the beauty of the USSR
about to launch sister rappin and now we
have missiles now for some damn reason
I am I getting hit am I getting what am
I getting hit by I can't even tell
anywhere there's too many things on the
screen I can't tell okay so anyway why
am i getting why am i getting hit why am
i getting up oh that's why I'm getting
hit cuz they're coming back down the
same rate that I'm seeing him going up
okay so anyway like the beauty oh the
beauty of seeing oh that Canada the
Canada send a walrus up here before I
got here wait USSR humiliated USSR beat
to space that bastard how could he how
can he do this debate oh I'm angry now
okay oh we gonna fight why are we gonna
fly why is it boy hey okay all right
then I guess is happening now yeah okay
V Omega walrus I'm not I don't even have
a chance Siri cuz cuz I'm like uh uh uh
I got I got to make my own country proud
you know I guess I gotta do this for
Mother Russia and all my Russian fans
walk out okay alright well um okay
all right well I can't see okay gotta
make my country proud oh my god oh my
god oh my god can't see a damn thing
holy hell on a handbasket I don't even
understand anything's happening what I'm
gonna do
Oh God Oh God okay oh my god I did it
oh okay that's it then Jesus that was
like I mean my god
I'm at a loss for words it's people
can't even fathom like the
ridiculousness
that's the great thing about Jam tbo too
is his concepts are just entirely
ridiculous and I mean this is other game
called Hedgehog launch that's really fun
too but I haven't played this one and my
god that was absurd but amazing I guess
that's it so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you want to play this
game and other games that he's made
check the link in the description below
thanks again everybody for watching and
check out the other crazy cool games
that I played in the past and as always
I'll see you in the next video winners
ones I mean everyone can see how
beautiful you are
oh please can hide the shadow in my soul
uh-huh uh-huh really good in it last
[ __ ]